hey hey we are back me and Mike
it's Tuesday welcome to game SWAT live
high two days in a row two days in a row
today we are checking out the outbreak
missions as well as a operation chimera
which is new to Rainbow six siege my key
bindings are the same on here they
should my servers are currently working
from what we can tell yeah a match
energy it took me a while to get in but
yeah I got in cool it was pretty fast
for despite the fact I don't like I'm
sure a lot of people are getting in
today so this is my I don't know what we
want to show first you want to show
multiplayer with the characters or
outbreak oh it's up to you I feel like
I'll start off with multiplayer and okay
sounds good
as you could see if you guys didn't
notice it oh [ __ ] so I don't have all
the love characters unlocked on this
profile this is my profile that got um I
had some trouble got locked out of it a
while ago but I've got everybody and
then here's lion for those of you who
haven't seen him in free coverage he's
one of the obviously both oh we're
getting red in can you turn game play up
I don't hear any gameplay hello here we
go this is weird yeah that's weird I
don't know why it's so low someone might
turn to that I didn't know yeah it was
going back into the rotation sweet
what's up Rueben mobs how are you doing
uh who should I be finca or lion first
he descended a periscope - yes I can't
I'll be finca she's so both characters
are attackers you see lion on the far
left he's the one who's a drone will
like reveal people if they're moving
after a small countdown is that like the
earthquake type thing more or less it
like it looks like it's like rumbling
yeah so it's like kind of like the
indicator like hey yeah and then you
gotta think I hear who I'm playing she
is she's like the offensive duct doc so
she can revive people or give them a
boost from anywhere on the map okay
right now wow I haven't played yacht in
the longest time well you're gonna play
now if gameplay I wanna there so yeah
you can see it earlier because their
picture and picture was kind of blocking
it but I'm playing I'm playing casually
I wanna play ranked No
on apparently I got reworked according
to Carl Magnuson but yeah a few of the I
didn't know I don't think they announce
it yeah I was back I'll take a look at
have the passion their reworking some
things I know they're like they did
redid hair for a base and every map
pretty much got a little bit of reworked
but I didn't know yacht was coming back
that's a huge thing maybe that was a
surprise they saved don't know what I
was trying to say is that outbreak if
you guys couldn't see it because our
picture and picture was in the way it's
there for like 27 days and whatever it's
like four weeks sorry key term gameplay
Lamar I'm probably gonna get [ __ ] up
on this stream just because this game is
not easy I know why I'm having to boost
this all the way so something is there
somebody messed with the audio settings
potentially or this game is just very
quiet no I just came I mean there will
be loud when stuff starts happening
louder alright well yeah I think it's
great I'm not the biggest fan of this
weapon heard prototype assault rifle
right now Spratly said they didn't
announce it oh cool I didn't know that
sweet so favela obviously in the back
but I'm gonna go in so if anybody gets
down
oh man I'm rubber-banding right now
surprise well I mean you can play on the
other internet line and hope that you
don't get kicked no but I need to do
that Wow
but this one is yeah you have red bar
right now I think from the top right my
ping is twenty thousand twenty eight
hundred yeah about the a kick this is
the most infuriating thing of my life
I'm not kidding like well like I said we
can gamble
you wanna gamble no like that's way
worse we get kicked off are you sure are
you sure though cuz I thought the other
one was worried that is we can try but
everyone was saying it's working more
than normal the second hopefully you
have yellow pain no my god I could just
do outbreak you can try it is out music
a basketball but yeah we basically are
firewalls for our internet here in the
office are like really bad no it still
happens I mean well if you pull we got
to pull all the way you got to go all
the way out and
don't know if it's just that one match
or not yes there was like that's that's
on our end though so yeah it's up to you
I mean have you played on that other
like out there like when you guys play
yeah
have you played on the normal not the
not on one that's set up I'm just trying
to figure I'm not trying to switch
anything right now I'm just trying to
get back into one match I don't know
you're in that's why I don't have to do
anything everyone thought you were
switching lines because I was going
you're gonna pull it no I was gonna I
have to reset it I mean I could try one
more time one more time otherwise but
yeah outbreaks only around for a month
so if you're trying to do that or trying
to experience that you should get in cuz
yeah what is that noise it's like
somebody's hammering something this is
awkward
you guys probably can't hear but
someone's like literally like nailing
something into the wall or something I
know well yeah we'll try again we'll see
what happens that was also an LS all
roaming around on your cam also you got
a guy just talking which hopefully he
just sounds like he's doing the right
thing and not being a jerk oh is this
you taking your spot back mmm
oh it's not because it's zero zero huh
yeah yeah well how's your ping now it's
fine well it goes back and forth it
might they also I don't know our
internet is finicky here but yeah we're
looking at permanent solutions down the
road so that mic stops getting rayji
from yeah bad internet I'm not the only
one no I know it's it's plague giant
bomb to our sister site and so we're in
the final stages of getting some other
internet put in that we can just play
games on and not worry about firewall
and all that stuff or NAT type issues
blah blah blah all that stuff no your
Internet's bad I can see it it's
flickering yellow maybe not okay
what's that one what's the same exact
thing yeah that's going up and down
alright
ooh look at that headshot I don't like
her prototype Rosewall that much but
people are like anything okay she
boosted did you boost herself there's a
one covering rainbow for a few months
now
gladly ooh flashbang themselves kill him
what is he doing he was right to hit the
ground in front of him maybe he was
flash man no you I mean we saw what he
saw I think he just thought it was like
friendly someone dead or something I
don't know
so this is lying you could see what
those vector ooh they're just lining up
oh can this guy clutch it out when we
three he's got
man I'm a small clutch you smell clutch
yeah should be alright it's a recruiting
some guy just left yeah he was already
dead I don't know why no one else
entered though
yeah the mirrors on the other side of
wall got her oh he told it told you I
know sorry dang what a clutch ammo one
gaming was not a fan of favela somebody
wants Bella
that'sall Tofino is very salty about
this being a Rainbow six game biggest
slap in the face neighbor who liked
Rainbow six one and two
I love Rainbow six one and two and I
love this I hate I feel like what
happened with this game and I don't know
this for a fact what I'm just gonna
guess or hypothesize it's like maybe it
went through this thing that Titan went
through with blizzard right I did it
went from patriot exactly that's a known
thing so ok so like have they actually
come out and said like it was like this
other thing and then now we just showed
a part of it they showed off Patriots
and then said what do you say I don't
know I was tryna have a conversation
with the audition and then you got this
comment like I mean he's being he's not
being yeah he's fine he's fine you don't
have to hopefully he doesn't say
anything it's important uh here we go
with frost being this was her map
actually she came out with this so let's
see there are a lot of changes yeah I
wouldn't even it's it's the biggest
thing I'm just gonna link it because I
thought I could read some of it it's map
changes but it's also there's operator
changes too yeah them unit on date blitz
is much better I don't know if I want to
go to blitz though oh he was did you see
how Opie he was but it was because it
was a bug and test yeah when the test
servers they made him too fast
no they said it was a bug at first they
they personally made him too fast and
they scaled him back and that was a bug
Oh guys they were trying to he was still
pretty fast we're dead I don't know I
just saw the community dove or community
manager like write a tweet out saying
like oh no we know that he's he's
currently like messed up
and it was because like he said he was
moving faster than he was supposed to
yeah off of like the kills and stuff
like that but yeah he was pretty strong
I had Ryan messing around in the game
with him just to see and I was like no
just just melee that guy and he's like
melee the crap out of the guy in the
corner didn't do anything okay so I
can't move when Lyons counting down or
else he'll see me unless I'm mute and
I'm within a jammer so that's over
so streaming this game I mean not
streaming but like you need volume for
this game obviously but I'll turn it up
I might play like a cab next time or go
Rome so it's not as boring to watch
I still got one more bear trap to place
here we go
damn it got me whoa I was even qivana
missed it
she got has my bear trap too I walked I
was like eh yeah whoa a little spider
yeah charm
they just counted down again see if you
have mute the defender no one's using
him right now I should you can put down
his jammers and lions drone won't see
you even if you're moving mm-hmm the
counter yeah got a I got it uh someone
got on my bear trap I got the assist
no nice you put down two of those right
yeah I usually put down three but I was
in kit in case people are going blitz I
saved the last one I saved the last one
because I can kind of like bait them
into it and put it around a corner if
they're using a shield person and
because blitz is better I'm I was
thinking someone would be going blitz
but mm didn't work out that way
they're so few operators out today well
well I think you already tried one time
there's one of them or what seems fine
now I think maybe you tried last game
and then my connection was awful but now
it's good so I don't know maybe he's hit
or miss maybe is the that one game who
knows
um but yeah checking those new operators
out and then we'll eventually get into
some outbreak PvE infected against the
infected I keep I kept calling their
zombie but aliens infected yeah the
other assist like better ooh nice
alright well cuz I got a welcome at and
I heard he Bona
sweet so this is like the game that
you're pretty much like spending what's
your time on now right yeah I would say
that and this in Monster Hunter nice
yeah you put out a couple pretty solid
features about Rainbow six siege so if
you guys haven't seen those yet she
check them out he also got to go to the
event you're also working on like like a
piece that's coming out soon with Jake
I'll call Magazine no vigil does not
counter I asked that so mutes the only
one that can hide vigil doesn't counter
because they were saying since he hacks
attack cameras and makes himself
invisible on them it didn't make sense
because the drone was his movement based
and not video based they said they might
change that down the road just to make
vigil a little more powerful because
he's a little bit underpowered but no he
does not
ah bi me and Jake have a thing Jake's
editing it goes up yeah there we go
goes up really soon hopefully yeah it's
about making operators in like the road
to 100 operators in Rainbow six siege it
famously said that they want a hundred
operators eventually and at the rate
they're going I wouldn't worry out right
now 38 okay it's always with today if
you have the so oh come on yeah yeah
yeah oh never go if you have
the season 3 pass the new operators are
live today if not they will be live next
week ok for free no no no if you have a
season pass they're free someone pick
them already whatever we can still see
how they work um I'll go back on his I
kind of saw that coming today I was like
yeah you know the operators are out
everyone's gonna want to try that's the
great the best part about the game so if
I get down she doesn't need to see me to
revive me and she can also buff me if
I'm about to rush the objective and I'm
playing buck just cuz this is his the
map that he came out with so how does
she revive you without singing she a
noob like me that doesn't play this like
Laura wise or just in the game show like
show she'll be able to see that you're
down you could tell her I'll she'll see
the medical sign the cross and she'll
just like press a button and you'll get
revived with 25% health doc on defense
revised people 50 but he needs like
shoots you with like a little dart range
so he's more powerful but in a different
way he is like from what I can tell he
is definitely a must-have for outbreak
though lion no doc um to heal yeah I
would say that's that's very young rich
I was really good on outbreak for his
British turret where we seen other down
kichaka is really good people are
excited that schanke's and people are a
fan of the chunka he's just not the best
okay they got a mute they're playing
smart they're just using mute to counter
but you can see they're in here the
walls fortified and I just got back up
so just so you guys know I linked some
of the updates and changes that are
coming with this update oh this is
sneaky I like this Mike saying Tatanka
yeah the chunk is good an outbreak nice
we'll see that in a little bit we're
gonna play a little bit more someone's
linking a giveaway in the chair right
now secret hot dog no he I think he's
looking for a giveaway there is no
giveaway huh
something up you know buck his his
gadget is just a shotgun in barrel so he
can breach really well this could be bad
there right on the other side so she
just buffed us you could see that close
20 homey it's a less recoil more help
all right this is Steve Adams I
shouldn't be going in yet but whatever
for the stream like yeah
let's go yeah yeah nice
oh he's behind the bar um look at him
yeah
sneaking under that dead body oh so he
was still there after that other guy
died yeah he died under the frost that
was my fault I kind of just was
impatient so she just used that again so
you can see because he wasn't moving
lion didn't yeah
couldn't didn't see it or didn't have it
ping on the map right or he could have
been moving if he was inside the mute
jammer okay
did they reduce the price of some old
year operators um yeah so all the
original operators are free now like if
you get the game I didn't really help at
all with that but whatever
there's lie and there's think I have the
same I took think of selling it off and
gave her a different skin as well but um
if you the Kyle Gass product is a good
name if you just get the game now all
the original operators will be unlocked
see if I got a pack so Erin said we can
unlock some packs if people want to say
that the outbreak packs I got one I
heard like they don't give you a dupes
or anything like that to which is
outbreak back specifically yeah so I'll
leave quick hopefully that doesn't screw
us up sure are you sorry you're gonna
get some or do I need back on me or
anything I wasn't sure if this was like
a Joey situation when we're doing
overwatch and he's got to go like oh
I'll purchase some stuff so how do I I
don't even know how to get these let's
check to buy them no there's other ways
I mean I guess I could oh yeah so you
can pay for these specifically with the
Remo six credits that's weird let me
open this one they're definitely doing
some hot construction outside I can hear
like a see I got look at that ombre for
the Lions got that it's uh it's all the
French characters weapons oh it's only
one thing it's just it's a weapon skin
for whoever has that web
I expected more things in that pack for
some reason no no that's not situation
so I'll do a little more multiplayer
okay and then cuz you're outbreak token
black II have the update the update is
out so I believe everybody can play
outbreak but unless you have the year
three past you have to wait another week
for the two new operators but luckily I
have the year three pass so I have lion
and finca unlocked I was due a few
people here and I hate this map whatever
cool and he hates this map also I linked
in chat earlier the update changes
everything
there's a bunch so you guys can peruse
that at your leisure
there's too many for me to read I kind
of scroll then I kept scrolling and I
kept scrolling so bright its usual Thank
You Oscar dais I think who wrote up this
article because there's a lot of stuff
there's like operator changes there's
game-mode changes Wow you know what who
said that I don't know I definitely just
lowered them because we don't need that
although yeah I think yesterday was um
yesterday was the day that they added it
was the day where I think they're saying
like you're not gonna get banned for
racial slurs and stuff like that yeah
they're they're like heightening their
homophobic and racial slur banning yeah
that's good you just really don't need
the toxicity yeah that's for sure trippy
torch outbreak is out today which is
that it's a PvE horde based mode it's
gonna be a limited time event it's you
know four weeks but you can just go in
and play that one's free right outbreak
yes yes for a month for a month yeah and
then it it's I think it's gonna be like
the overwatch stuff where it comes and
goes like maybe it's not always outbreak
but it's like you know outbreaks there
for four weeks gone for like a couple
weeks comes back and then the tuning
operators are out if you have this
season three I think I still have some
fishin that they'll make outbreak
permanent
heard some things okay it's not
confirmed at all so new maps no new
modes no outbreak for now thank you you
kill me I'll be so pissed because these
guys sound like they're in a party
together well you weren't the one that
there I think they're talking trash to
the other team they were talking trash
to IQ the character fine thank you thank
you I don't know people this community
wavers between great and terrified yeah
I mean I feel like that's the case in a
lot of competitive games though yeah
unfortunately which is some of the stuff
that people have to weather the storm in
terms of like those kind of people but
you know there is the mute function so
there's always that
y'all can't move except for that guy oh
that guy's a pro guy that probably shot
you hun ran ooh nice
how come you know get an assist for that
is that wasn't the same guy oh yeah you
detected him do he might not he might
have just shot someone that wasn't
moving oh no that guy definitely was
moving I saw him on your on the on the
UI or whatever yeah outbreak goes but
the new operators stay a stone echo
mentioned yeah
it's really hard to break that relit
habit yep I should with him he's got 50
round mag yeah because I saw Aaron he
like mopped up two people one Matt but
there it was like a1 b3 and he you know
instinctively thought like I cleared out
two people I can reload safely and it
was not so right now I know where he's
[ __ ] don't mind me I'm just gonna
keep talking they're not alright sweet
things though I think he's objective we
can [ __ ] push oh he's getting lit up
nice that vigil could've easily killed
me I was switching from my drones though
is it Yaga and his old World War two our
pilot uniform sees some people in chat
satellite canal it is definitely
balanced between attack and defend I
agree I just I personally always talk on
it and we be gaming asking is there any
rewards for completing the mission the
outbreak mission stuff I think you still
like level up from what I remember um no
it's not the same progression okay oh no
no no it's not no no you have all the
attachments unlocked you get yeah I
think that's how you get outbreak packs
well okay actually can you look that up
how to get operate packs because I
haven't done them in those test server
say some people that we're playing test
server like have everything already
right second one down maybe this one or
this one second
turn this down right now as you're just
prepping which right now about a break
packs outbreak packs will not provide
you with any gameplay elements and will
only cut contain cosmetic items the
outbreak collection is composed of 50
unique items no duplicates now the new
the new characters stone echo are in
multiplayer unless you're talking
specifically about recruits in that case
oh like skin wise if that's every time
like yeah you're right they're only an
outbreak as far as like gameplay goes
they are in this they will continue they
will contain Universal weapon skins
unique weapon skins headgear uniforms
charms as well as turnover the gameplay
for yeah but how do I get okay I'll
bring packs can be a only be acquired
for 300 are six credits each starting on
march 2 6 my dad sucks that being said a
few other outbreak the game plan it's
like max that being said a few other
outbreak rewards will be available
through gameplay and I get my armor and
wears not green anymore blue and will be
awarded based on other criteria to be
disclosed at a later date okay yeah this
guy I I think this together are talking
to you just what is he doing oh [ __ ] I
read the rest of it at least
so there's no way
whoo my shot sorry don't worry I'm just
trying to I got excited I love shooting
montane in the face I'm not tough so
you're done yeah I love this gun also I
don't know why I like the mac-11 a lot
shouldn't I I guess it's good what its
angle
it's dirty angle well Piazza time Pizza
is time might be in the room to your
right
damn and I got three of you guys mm-hmm
all right as time back to reading this
all players that logged in during the
outbreak event will receive for outbreak
packs immediately did you get those all
characters that what all players that
log in during the outbreak event will
receive for outbreak packs immediately
but those of you who are not in the game
and purchased the Advanced Edition
before or during the outbreak event you
will receive the ten packs that are
included in the Advanced Edition at the
start of the event
plus the for logging in black beard you
can use your outbreak skins in
multiplayer games yeah I think their
time specifically about the recruits
cash I don't you might be able to I
don't know that'd be cool but the
recruits look like castle now and
multiplayer is a character so I think
he's on the stairs I don't think I'm
we'll have to see if you got those four
packs though I don't at this last time I
checked I might just need to play
outbreak like one time to get like as a
reward yeah this guy easily just plant
on B but this guy's not really doing
much to stop that it's a black beard
though I don't know if you know him the
character no I think I was like that
goes over his gun that uh look can
prevent headshots for a few shots he was
really overpowered at first
now his shield breaks though
and that's the opposing he's enough of
us oh he's on yeah yeah this is a mute
right here this is Brooke who gives
armor oh wait it out the real he has to
plant like the bomb this is real Shar
balloon so this dude getting behind them
you should get that then when you login
I don't know I would try again after
yeah we didn't get any just now so I'm
not sure Piazza Piazza I got the assist
for it yeah you did some damage so for
sure my Mac 11 at ranges we look at
sneak potty do you normally play on PC
Mike I yes nowadays I do I started on
ps4 until like rank 100 something
I'll go flying again but yes I pretty
much prefer a PC with this game my
account recently I got blocked out of a
you play account for kind of my fault
kind of like it also got hacked and I
didn't like go through the right
procedure
it was my Steam account gotcha so now
I'm just working back but the regrind
yep I don't mind though this games
really fun to play
I'm going lying again I like Lions
weapon more than finca and I also his
ability I think is I don't know they're
both really useful abilities actually
what's up JP money hope you're doing
well today hope you're all doing well
today then guys beginning they're not
here
other side oh they're in the West
building not sure where though the Blitz
getting over how are they took they
toned up they dialed down his speed a
little bit be still pretty fast and I
like the new textures green arrow I mean
it's a minor thing but they look really
good the textures on the character icons
oh they spawn peaking yeah there are a
lot of passion Hannibal good luck
someone's spawn peeking us the old hope
that they walk into it you know like it
you got a pretty fire in this game
sometimes yeah definitely all right that
crane is in my way I'm good so this the
drone is great when you are like finally
going to the objective and
you located a bomb
nobody damn they handle that well well
he happened just kill that one guy and
then probably just stopped knowing oh
one of my guys yeah one of your guys got
killed yes all right I should be droning
more I'm not really right now so I'm
kind of actually I'll do that now what
was that
I'll read some of these questions after
this round so just keep filling up the
questions and I'll send them over to
Mike nice shot I like this gun much more
than fincas so that was vigil I think I
can't tell we didn't scan okay oh he's
got three scans I've been doing it under
the assumption he has to okay that
changes things
Oh 3v1 well you can't move now right
should have this guy flanked
nope oh [ __ ] sorry it's the me better I
see him yep new Meadows flashbang
yourself yep nice well-played City there
you go that's what you gotta do when you
got the advantage pinch em yeah pinch
him what do you think of my you know
David Byrne is no I don't lead singer of
Talking Heads but it's spelled
differently so I spelled it burn okay I
see I see
it's clever its clever it's pretty
clever alright alright here let me read
some of this stuff what do y'all think
about the Asha elite skin task turtle
boys games I haven't seen it so I don't
know have you seen it we think about
what Ash's elite skin I like it
she's got like her glasses and hat
completely off nice
so let me as you could tell this is
still I'm relatively low rank um won't
really low rank for most people four and
one not bad okay cool
so let me leave that again just to
double check in the outbreak BOGO like
it I guess I could play out right now
sure yeah if you want to give it a go we
didn't get those packs though huh no
that's weird
hmm and I read that from stray from the
UV so oh is that the Ashkan yeah I don't
know so he's like yeah yeah yeah it'll
I've seen em and some of our thumbnails
yeah I don't know why I know do you want
buy some don't I mean we could but let
me let me play outbreak see if that
helps
okay no you like you said it shouldn't
some people are someone in chat said
it's when you log in so I don't know
it's not right there yeah we're our pet
maybe I did the login the outbreak how
do we want to watch this actually no
okay you can watch this on our site we
can pile all of them mm-hmm Aaron put
them together so
you want to watch those outbreaks go
check all those cinematics we've
compiled into one video if you want to
watch it I wish I think Aaron's online I
could try inviting him he was online oh
he's all right okay
hopefully he gets yeah but we'll see how
his internet is he might drop out on you
see the problem with this seam what ion
cast from what I noticed at least on the
test servers was that like it didn't
fill it in after was that your
experience I mean like obviously your
experience was a land experience so it's
probably not the same but it was weird
that nobody sorry so one if somebody
drops in outbreak
you don't like it didn't put repopulate
the person so you ended up only having
two people when we did test server at
least that did not happen and I heard
that happens in other mission stuff so I
uh so not every character is available
for outbreak yes like what ten was at 10
operators nine or ten yeah yeah I think
the two new ones are yang to Chaka who's
great I might actually use the chunka I
don't know we'll see
maxie gaming yes outbreak mode 610 yeah
you're right outbreak mode is limited
it's scheduled at least for now for four
weeks
finca so she's good as well as daca so
you can revive people do y'all think
another question from turtle boy games
do y'all think they should keep outbreak
yeah I think so
as long as you're gonna be weird with it
I don't I mean I get it I get how like
things like destiny destiny sorry
destiny overwatch do those divisions I
get it in division yeah which I was
telling you I kind of got back recently
I do think they should keep this I think
it adds a new dimension to it and
there's they put my thing is I can't
imagine them taking away because even
more than overwatch they put what four
new cutscenes into it they put I mean if
they put a ton of work into it the maps
are huge they're not they're not like
it's not a game mode like overwatch put
into the existing maps it's three new
brand new maps that could take like 40
minutes to beat each guy I don't know
it's weird thangka I would like them to
yeah just so it's an option like the
play like I
see this giving some people into the
game that might not have been into it
previously so there's finca I just you
know going in without a gas mask into
this contaminated area I'm on the other
side of the fence and I only say that
because I think you should I should have
put a suppressor on you kind of get your
fill with this after you know like
there's only three Maps right and I mean
I think it's nice to have limited events
I know people are probably be upset with
me for saying that but it really does
kind of bring people back to the game
that you know like otherwise you might
have drifted off if you have this mode
all the time maybe yeah maybe as one of
the people in chat mentioned this is
like one of the sole reasons are gonna
play the game but I feel like by having
limited event time events it does really
bring people back and then it makes that
experience kind of like you want to play
it in that moment now I understand some
people are like afraid that like you
know like what if they're not there but
four weeks is a long time I figure it
within the four weeks if you can't play
a mode like you must have been out on
like a work trip for a month which would
really suck obviously yeah I mean it
happens but it's you know it's with
timed events there's only Solon if
they're gonna so I mean they could keep
it but then I feel like that sets the
precedent for down the road if they do
ten runs people be like oh no it's
eventually gonna be permanent I don't
need to go back now so that could be a
dangerous precedent to set that being
said like it's crazy how much work they
put into this for just a month long
event like they've said it's a gift to
players be it's like there's 27 million
players now yeah more than that I would
be surprised if it doesn't cross 28 in
the next two months
that's just like a how fast is growing
you could see if you don't kill the
those dudes soon enough then you they
get putt more powerful and also
suppressor helps because then there's
yeah well here's the other thing maybe
see thermite without his stuff on it's
cool like these characters little
tidbits are great for people who care a
bit the other thing to consider actually
that I just thought about alright
someone else has thought about is that
like maybe this is like the testbed yeah
like a month to see like how many people
actually how many users engage with this
mode and then they can build upon it if
there's enough friction there if there's
enough people that like really
maybe playing Rainbow six siege only for
this mode I could definitely see that
happening this dude right here is
buffing everybody that's I'm trying to
kill that oh that's a guy that throws
stuff at you and like kind of like pans
you down yeah have you died to this
stuff yet huh have you died at all in
this mode at all now yeah like like
sorry like current like died died like
as interrogation yes okay cool [ __ ] get
out of my way dude
sorry its are walking the doorway um but
the cool thing if you guys haven't seen
it and I'm not gonna tell them like to
fail is that each monster has its own
kind of like killing action yeah they're
like Grimm - yeah like the apex woman
why did you that what good did that do
button alright whatever
don't be one of those guys no I but I'm
not saying it to him I'm just thinking
out loud I wouldn't say it to him you
guys gotta come over here come in doc
maybe you need one of those like little
wheels you know like a little chat wheel
thing come on I think even if you do
that on him it'll it'll spawn them over
yeah that makes sense
you see I love the how the nanobot thing
looks on her arm it's on her right here
on earth lens like some yeah Arturo can
Torrens asking is this free I mean the
mode is free yeah everything in Rainbow
six can be free it's just I it's not a
lock now if you didn't pay for the earth
repast you don't have these characters
yet outbreak do you know if they're
locked if so like if you have if you
don't have your three right you're
playing outbreak okay so they're still
locking outbreak not an outbreak but
okay but in multiplayer okay again take
this to the green so I could be
completely wrong that's my understanding
okay again I'm lucky enough to have
years we pass yep which it's worth it
like just with this game I mean you know
like you could say what you want about
Ubisoft trying to get you good puck by
money that's I get it for sure well I
mean it doesn't feel as yeah that's the
only thing I don't like about the
outbreak packs is you can spend real
money on them but there's no duplicates
so that's yeah every cosmetic it's
cosmetic and there's no duplicates it's
still shady you know like like you can
this is the first time you can spend
real money on random packs although like
they are
because you could Rainbow six credits
are you spend real money on them I mean
this is a good time to use it
I've never really had a problem with and
I've said this on multiple streams where
the the the payment stuff is tied to
Cosmetics yeah because it doesn't
influence how people play the game it's
just aesthetics but it's yeah and hey in
my in my mind I'm like yeah it's it's
predatorial potentially but if it put in
if it also potentially gets you more
maps for this mode like I'm fine with it
if the people want to spend the money
and then it ultimately Nets us more
missions or more modes in like outbreak
because people enjoy outbreak then
that's cool that's fine whatever but
that's just me that's my Oh apparently
Chandler would said they're blocked on
both oh gosh I didn't know that that's
that kind of sucks them so we're
defending this room now because you
would think that they would use outbreak
as a platform to be like hey you liked
playing that operator well to play him
or her in a multiplayer you gotta unlock
them or by the pass oh yeah AWS green
arrow yes we have seen the death
cutscene I've seen some of the death
cuts in Simon small hope maybe you'll
get to see him I don't want to well you
know how we'll see him if you play on
pandemic pandemic pretty tough it was
even unlocked it was prison wires on and
pendant yep it is which I liked and left
for dead friendly fire was always on
speaking of left for death turns to 10
this year so I think oh really any later
to stream it yeah it was October
definitely can do that but yeah dynamics
really pretty rough we were playing and
oh you play ryan played a pandemic just
to see cuz the chat wand is here and
it's pretty tough
this gun is good and some oh shut the
dock again hit it's okay you can always
revive her yeah you can use ours bait
sacrificial lamb thanks Chandler wood
for that information we should
keep the riveters liver 420s does this
mug give context to the backstory of the
new characters and if so they should
keep it yep
they are literally so girl I'm playing
finca is Russian Iommi's my nanobots
because [ __ ] this
oh there's a [ __ ] digger she is
Russian but she joined this like she's a
specialist in like anti bioterror so
that's why her and lion who's French got
called in to help with this stuff gotcha
and as you can see you could tell she's
Russian she's not using the UN scope she
has the Spetsnaz mm-hmm
Green Arrow says you can get the
operators for 25,000 right now on the
13th yeah and then at some point I don't
know if now the original operators will
be free and okay should I escort I don't
think so
I'll let you yeah he's got it I should
refill my charge yeah that thing's not
dead
you're also like 50 health I know I
can't oh right that's everything vault
yeah I just I used my nanobot thing
during that flame let me I need that the
grenade crate to refill it hi i live i
GN more
alright you live them more thanks Henry
Devils Reaper says do you guys think
they'll add knife skins nice skins I
think it was a joke
that'd be you know Oh shits the
preservative thing oh I'm out of ammo
and he's right next to the ammo box get
it get it get it get it get it get it
get so that guy's fun he's like the tank
from like left 4 dead right yeah he's
blind one guy he's like the Berserker
from Gears of War he's blind I could
hack if he runs into the wall and gets
done you can melee him yes God why do I
keep tapping that I've seen it where you
kind of melee the back right yes I was
like an assassin II do it do it do it
no you didn't do it didn't get stuck
yeah do it
run do a wall I like how he used like a
trail of thorns sweet dude come on run
gets mad damn it oh he definitely ran
yeah just didn't hit the wall
there's a post count heart color there
you go
yeah oh it doesn't kill him huh no I
need like two or three for those but you
can still keep shooting him around the
Rosie he's definitely messed up yeah I
can see it's more exposed or like
there's a bigger gas or whatever any
more animal actually no I don't eat
grenades and nanobots they're dos nice
the manager called nice
ooh Oh so those dudes are cool because
if you shoot the yellow things they
explode and they're easier to kill their
to shoot their body they don't explode
[Music]
yeah they're gonna need create with
stuff there it is so sweet I gotta get
those quick sweet got my nanobots back
got grenades you can use some health I
don't know if there's any around and is
what it is somehow this is going better
than when let's playing and I don't know
if that's just cuz these guys are trying
harder or not also we did have a lot of
people like dropping out and leaving and
stuff I don't even want to jinx it right
now I feel like I just jinxed it though
yeah it's like an alien infection yeah I
can stop calling them zombies I just
call him zombies but infected oh we play
rocket League and now all you guys are
some of the first to say my name right
well at least there was that Heinrich
IGN wouldn't say your name right yeah I
guess so sure Paul Sutherland says do
you guys play rocket League we used to
play a lot we kind of stopped then we
started playing again more recently and
just realized at least I realized how
bad I am at that game so I'll stick to
the stuff I normally play is this the
next part of the mission okay look how
the doctor is wearing a converse so
refilled everything pretty much don't
know why this is all here if we just
refilled who wants to ask order you
again yeah I don't think I don't think
wines ability is super great on outbreak
oh they come at us okay when you're like
there's in the junk err map which I like
you're defending that house mmm and
that's helpful if you could see which
where they're coming from yeah
hello over the room
how are you what's poppin hunter uh-oh
64 thanks for tuning in checking out
that an outbreak one of three missions
that are available for a limited time
one also gonna probably hop back into
some casual matches with the new
operators at some point god I reload so
much I'm so sorry that's alright it's a
it's a habit that even though I outbreak
is a good mode to get rid of it
oh to try to give her their characters
and weapons you need it obviously but
like the last thing you want to do is go
into a fight see it so we shot him the
body he didn't blow up button you took a
little bit more to kill but like Lyons
gun the 51 round drama I gotta stop
reloading so early on that it's a muscle
memory thing I could kill the entire
yeah I press square on controller and
then are on keyboards I could kill an
entire team with Lions drum if I didn't
know reload suck it's definitely a hard
one to break a hard habit to break
and you have to have I feel like it's a
confidence thing too because if you're
really confident then you're you're like
cool I don't care if I have ten bullets
because I'm gonna be accurate you know
and kill yeah you know or get rid of
whoever I need to but yeah I definitely
struggle with it too oh my god this is
not a good place go go like why are you
shooting down the door oh okay there's
no other way out of here
yeah there's oh yeah there's always a
way get out of that room see so that was
that's good yeah yeah okay sweet okay
sorry no the doctor can you know she's
sacrificial lamb like it's not like that
she dies I thought she does die she she
might but I'm just saying you could
always survivor oh [ __ ] doc just helped
her right
god damn it doc double-deal man yeah
it's good it's good it's good he's doing
a job I did my job I over did my job
yeah Ricky Williams asking how are you
guys liking the event so far me I don't
play as much Rainbow six siege but I
always like seeing PvE modes in
competitive shooters I think it's a nice
thing to have because there's definitely
a different demographic of players that
will either enjoy this more than you
know some of the competitive shooter
people but it's always nice to have that
variety I feel like or if I'm reviving
I'll get him oh you just don't care he's
like the kool-aid man who just breaks
down doors or walls rather gosh I wish I
might oh [ __ ] there's some earth there
in case someone gets down again well
gadget God I got to stop doing that
get him get him get him get him nice out
of there he's almost done
here he's like holding on to the doctor
like save me don't come at me I was like
you are a bold man sir oh it was worth
it it's worth it yeah yeah yeah
disappear into the oh yeah okay yeah bag
teabag the Smasher Mike I won't do it
tell their humans that ever I never do
that I hate people who do that but it's
not actually I was gonna say you should
heal because you only had 50 bucks I'm
gonna heal everybody and then I'm gonna
go get a gadget yeah what's up game
where Jeff Roe are you doing yeah so
Heinrich says pinko will be useful an
outbreak and multiplayer where as line
will be more useful and why can't it
sorry yeah whereas line will be more
useful in just multiplayer yeah Keith
Richards we will be playing some casual
multiplayer for 20 yep Keith Richards
liver for 20 I just kind of stopped
saying the whole thing because it's
really long
let's see we are currently playing on
normal not yeah
we're not endemic lame pandemic no
pandemic has as Mike mentioned earlier
friendly fire which I like things are
something I was murdered it would like
people I know and yeah I feel like if
you guys are gonna do pandemic it's like
almost worth your time to kind of play
each mode try to get through each mode
or each map once just so you guys get a
feel of it and then that'll help you you
know yeah a better job in pandemic
whereas playing pandemic right I mean in
all fairness we have to wake up through
all the maps Pete oh yeah like people in
general
yeah I'm just giving them like a you can
try playing pandemic efforts right but I
think it's probably safer didn't warm us
to play regular play some get get
understanding of the maps so that you
can get through it because there's like
is it three phases for each map yeah two
or three maybe
you should have barricaded a little bit
badass sgt loader are you asking which
of the two operators really like more if
that's your question I guess I'll let
Mike answer that because I don't really
I personally know play too much seems
like a lion I like think his ability but
I like Lions weapon overall and him
overall his new weapon the ban on
assault it's slower firing weapon vector
than Mira's mirros is insanely fast um I
think that's hard to say who's better
Talaat Farook I think Lions pretty his
ability is very dangerous
hey that's - yeah like it's one of those
things where like people don't always
get down but so you don't always revive
me you can still boost them and like
both characters are really good for
pushing objectives it's like you're
right outside the objective wanna know
where they are and you're about to push
I could boost them and then lion could
reveal them or you could have fuse put a
fuse charge in the wall and then set it
off and then right when and although
getting pronate or scattering everybody
you use lions drones so that you can see
where they are
same with dhoka be a [ __ ] it's an apex
same with dopey apologies if you say
joke baby you said you can call their
phones so then they have to choose
between moving or just letting the phone
vibrate and letting you hear where they
are as I'm really interesting to see all
like the different combos and the
different uses of the abilities like at
one time you're using Lions ability like
kind of more offensively because you're
kind of pushing and you're like okay if
I you know if I deploy the drone they
can't move and that'll give you a better
chance to get tactical advantage have we
seen the outbreak charge that no we
haven't
or at least I haven't what what do you
think about that I guess like I'm I mean
all the uniforms are like those hazmat
outfits but the charms themselves are
there okay yeah Joseph jr. no classes
today looking good
I just took them off I don't really like
I'm nearsighted so being in here I don't
really need them oh sorry
I'm very good no I was talking about I
just you're saying sorry do the infected
know that I wasn't watching this side Oh
gotcha okay
Green Arrow asking what do you think
about yatra turning happy favelas next
hopefully although I like a lot more a
lot of people earlier said no TIF Avella
I like no I mean I get it yeah is right
above it but let's see
sorry grounded dreams question the games
had to stop doing their weekly chat
stream on the weekly music set arose
that they used to do on twitch or did
they just move the time and is it now
not you friendly Grindr dreams we have
stopped doing the lobby as of 2018
you're out of the way dude we've taken
some of those conversations that we
would normally have in a lobby sorry
there's no press it we've taken some of
those conversations that we normally
have about the lobby and kind of like
did I won't call it they're not like
necessarily one offs but we do like one
a week where we chat in the office about
some of those news topics or some of the
like some of the new games coming out
and things like that so you can look for
them there right now they don't have
like a branded naming behind them so the
funny thing for me to say is like if you
look like on YouTube GameSpot's youtube
you'll see that I will see that they
have a very distinct thumbnail style
stuff I can also link you to some if
you're interested grounded dreams
I shouldn't hopefully get a gadget soon
yeah you're gonna need someone in your
whole life now though he is good I'm
just like in thinking ahead
come over here dude
I just dock all the way back there come
on
where to go stop dead why can't I see
them oh how do you get a warped him
so that was helpful I guess Lions thing
to kind of just see where the majority
of them we're coming from free fire them
yeah are you low on ammunition no I just
switch they don't worry oh I definitely
am yeah guys coming in to pick us up
you know well that guy is like I'm just
not gonna go there get flashed Oh get
knifed ten rounds like Robert to Romero
what is this I thought there was a
multiplayer map this is the PvE outbreak
mode that has been added for free it's a
limited time event for weeks and yeah
you can try it out it's a you and two
other operators three operators in total
fighting against pretty much aliens or
like infected aliens whatever you want
to call them no there's got to be an
emoji so there's that and I'm helping me
because I need ammo the tuning operators
are part of this but you don't I guess
somebody had mentioned earlier if you
don't have them unlock that they're
locked
we can't tell you that for sure because
we had them unlock three yeah do you
think suppressed guns are helpful in
zombies you said were definitely are you
should suppress anything you can I just
forgot oh you just got globbed by the
apex I should pop my gadgets soonish
actually I could follow us to kill the
eight and each so you just like my
recoil is like gone when you get buffed
by that it's like a laser there's three
maps to my understanding and yeah but
there's like there are two or three
parts to each one yeah so like each one
has kind of like its own three things
two or three things that you have to do
this one were at the hospital escorted
the doctor escorted her out safely so
that's this one you go with Jager coming
in to get us you can see him in the
helicopter I believe there's like
another one with like hotel and I won't
donate her yeah it's like a resort
so that was outbreak yes mm-hmm now
we'll probably go back to playing a
couple more yeah Heinrich was saying the
same similar to what I was saying like
when you're planting the bomb if you
activate lines ability they're not going
to want to move to defuse it so you
still get renown just so you guys know
so I'm maybe I got OPEX now or maybe it
just didn't I don't know I don't know I
don't think so I don't know maybe that
that thing that I read from Yugi's blog
post is different or like old I don't
know all right little more casual I
guess maybe a nother matter - sounds
good
oh yeah you already told her bear so I
think but yeah yotz back and then um
gonna play some casual now outbreaks
just temporary
I don't know why I couldn't think of
that word stop yellow Sandra no or is
Roberto see if I can get one I think I
are lying
Arden either don't know you gotta be
quick everyone like feel like most
people are trying to play them right now
ninokuni - I don't know that we have I
mean I know I don't think we've said
though okay well I'm excited to try it
out I like the first one no I'm gonna
need these guys unfortunately that's
fine with our guns yep let's shoot him
with our guns someone's gone Cappy Tao
has his weapon got buff recently he was
like one of the most under played
characters aside from tachanka he was d2
chunk on offense what's up Rays Marv
Internet's been better since we
reconnected don't jinx it
I'm the best here look at look at look
at that paint no nevermind just asking
for trouble man I don't question it when
the internet love goes
I like house I wonder if all right
there's the there's like the only number
one rule of Rainbow six is you don't
barricade kids bedroom that's this
running thing yeah cuz if you barricade
this room when the bomb in here you just
Traverse oh let's up decks on yeah okay
question that was kind of asked earlier
but we'll answer it again which is do
you think out you're outbreak should be
permanent we both gave our points yeah I
think so I don't know I think it will be
that's my prediction but if not whatever
I'm the opposite I like that it's timed
I like that it brings people back also
like I said earlier is probably good
like a test see how how many people are
actually playing the the mode and how
many people enjoy it and you know if it
becomes a bigger thing you know I
wouldn't be shocked if he becomes more
of a permanent kind of get them a little
scare before we go in later is my thanks
for stopping way
Cappy Tao fire
damn I keep thinking I'm lying yeah I
was like your lion has not sent out his
drone yet I mean it's it's probably good
to save it when you really need it like
pushing objective but I it's still it
doesn't give you an extra levels have
you got three of them right I feel like
oh there he goes
yeah you're threes a lot there's one
okay so now Osama been hiding so that's
a pulse it looks like yeah so I don't
want to rush in there because there
could be someone else if we had that
line tag we would have found Osama a lot
sooner thinking about like five years
nor than that yeah do we found out we
found him in one scam oh that's one
right there they done I don't know all
right I'm gonna do what I wanna do going
through downstairs I guess yeah I could
do that really quick if anybody gets
down I could Lions messed up right now I
could if anybody gets down yeah I'll go
in through downstairs oh what's up we
tend Dan welcome back ninokuni God of
War sorts of ditto all on my radar sort
of ditto is coming out soon I think
well we got this rec room ID so now he's
up cuz I really that's cool you didn't
have to even be an LS that was helpful
because he fell off the roof and so is
he stuck at 25 life now yeah it's only
one guy there's no way all this guy
could clutch it oh I know there's two
notes too eager lion you want to pop
that he's doing it now
pulse is upstairs though it's Osama he's
still moving that Osama does that work
oh he's that which Thomas oh yeah you
can shoot through oh yeah I'm not a big
weapon it's close you're close to
killing them yeah yeah Yeager's his gun
didn't give me my free four packs what
do i do I don't know actually because we
have kind of going through the same nice
where we also didn't get them so let me
double check that that's actually
factually correct maybe they just
haven't maybe that's not gonna happen
til next week when everybody is live for
everyone
maybe that's the problem this is what I
read was from support I don't have any
attachments for
mm-hmm oh yes I do so all the
attachments are free now for everyone
which is great
I'm gonna go mute because he counters
lying really well Wow
it literally says all players that log
in during the outbreak event will
receive for outbreak packs immediately
huh that's what it says okay so I'm
going mute which is gonna help against
line a little bit if they're using a
lion or screaming there there's no date
on this article though so I'm gonna say
one of these four green arrow is saying
that potentially for next time you could
just save your ability because that
person was prior right next to them to
revive but I mean it's situational but
yeah that is a I don't agree with this
but I'm also gonna put this in the
corner so this will hide me from lions
thing I like need a lot Chris a asking
have you played on a older rig at all
like okay and it's not good it's fine
terrible it works okay cuz Chris a
basically asked how well do you think
the game will run on an eight-year-old
rig with 12 gigs of RAM I seven to 20
acres peak in with a GTX 970 I think
that you'd be fine you probably have to
lower some settings but a 970 is not a
bad card at all and if you have 12 gigs
around that seems pretty okay to like
really old well he said eight-year-old
it started off as eight-year-old so I
don't know maybe just give it a go and
see how it plays you might have to lower
some settings unfortunately I don't have
direct experience Chris a green arrow
was saying try resetting maybe for the
PAX I don't know yeah we can check later
we can check later on our way out just
to test they have three dead okay three
ev2 you said to their come from the east
I'll boost up gameplay for you please do
so I put my mute
jammer over there near Frost so if they
do have a line we can just hide it
that so they're probably the bathroom or
there or downstairs
either way I'm oh don't wanna go in that
one no thank you probably John Parker
chimera will last forever it's outbreak
that's only a month right now outbreak
mode okay so they know I'm here right
where I am so Mira's got her window here
I should just use that I don't know why
I'm out there so they can't see through
this for those who don't know and then
the only way she shoots through it is by
kind of like letting I wish I would have
put the other one here but oh well
breach action who's that that's finca so
if they have a lion he's either dead or
they haven't used him it might've been
one of the people kitty ager killed
right at the beginning the knee
operators are out for the year three
folks right but not out for everyone yet
correct I think they're available next
week for those that want to buy it with
renown oh did I get her don't not a hit
her once
didn't see any type of like blood
sweater or anything like this fine just
a poppet oh they thought the same thing
like chapter so he just is pushing into
kids room yeah they're in the walk
got the he Bona and that was a so ladies
and kids room now trying to go he Bona
again some you from that distance was
not great
is there is you answer that one finca
elite boughs or bows rather sorry I
don't know about Xbox updates
unfortunately give me that it give me
the Apple nice there we go second kill
assist coming up hopefully just kids
bathroom frost sorry bedroom they're
still in kids room Maximus garyun saying
restart your Xbox that could be a weight
room door come on come on he's pushing
hallway
signal this faster oh she just tried did
you see that yeah she's trying to use
her thing but my jammers
I guess the signal disrupter jams her
nanobots really that's pretty cool I'm
gonna keep playing with mute then DJ
bouncing Xbox update ten gigs really as
it's pretty crazy so that's pretty cool
trying to do it did did they anyone
confirm that
I don't know someone just said yeah care
to find out I don't think I'm gonna live
long enough for you to test it if they
are gonna run em you okay no what oh no
I told you you jinxed it man I didn't
know my sanity okay I'm literally this
can't be me okay that scared me I I you
know how like I'm back in the day when
we still use CDs and like the skipping
noise that are making those that is
equivalent to what I feel when like a
game starts lagging I hate it more than
I'm not like droning smart um I just
hate it more than I can't explain it
just gives me this very visceral like
rayji reaction visceral and I have to
suppress it got a Valkyrie Jake plays
Valkyrie I haven't played Valkyrie in a
while it's casual dude we don't need to
worry about that in pain hey man he's
trying to practice for competitive and
here you are playing like a filthy cash
okay
I'm gonna go in through downstairs again
and so some have been lagging that could
be it that was a good one Keith Richards
lag is real right now yeah
we've been mostly steady our internet
definitely here
corporate wise has a stronger firewall
so sometimes it messes with us on you
play hi good luck from Germany thank you
is all I miss or sorry if I butchered
your name
she got nerfed though still not enough
still not enough you don't think she's
she's still gonna be great damn that
those weights made me think there was a
person there Crouch I always hide behind
on to this it's like dude Mike there's a
person right there
no they're just weights I'm gonna wait a
little bit to go in so you used your
buff I didn't think it's always Osama
man Oh somewhat don't care you wish the
real one was that easy to find like you
said it's doing your job for a sec
that's fine please please do I'll have a
flash a little diversion yeah
okay a Valkyrie might have a camera in
there that I did not see hopefully not
who knows the way lion knows the way
that's true
somebody's watching side ster okay so
that's me
made a kill hole on it yeah thank you
yeah I like this guy he's just so
someone's in the workshop watching the
stairs
oh there's other known issues hold on
the see damn it
sorry Mike no up there okay just so you
guys know there's some there's our
article that we just wrote up a couple
hours ago there's some issues
potentially I guess Rainbow six siege is
free ash elite skin is not being awarded
right now
at least that was as of 11:40 a.m. so
that's actually 30 minutes ago what else
is there yeah so apparently one of the
eight ways that they were helping to
apologize was with Ash's sidewinder
elite skin which would be made available
to all players for free by playing a
match before match
March 6th the day of chimeras launched
so if you played before that you would
have qualified but some people are
reporting that they're not getting that
skin UV stop is aware of the problem and
a fixes in progress the same is also
true for the issue where the inventory
doesn't show the Damascus steel skin oh
really I was wondering about that I had
oh come on
oh she's resetting and if you haven't
received your free outbreak loot boxes
for logging in ubi soft says you should
simply restart the game to resolve it so
for those asking thank you Chris Pereira
for writing that article up so if you
haven't gotten your free outbreak packs
the four that you should get just
we start there and win this game there's
a dude above them this doesn't look good
apparently there's other problems that
haven't been addressed oh I don't know
why guys waited too long now whatever
they did better than I did so people are
saying think I makes her and her team
immune to flash that's dope is that when
she does the buff or just is that a
passive I'm curious because that's cool
hey I'm a infinity we're just playing
casual right now I was also because our
internet is sometimes suspect so I
wouldn't want to put Mike through that
or anyone that's playing a competitive
match that way to Daniel Doyle's almost
out of school so you can play ten
minutes left what time is it are you on
the East Coast this morning maybe unless
he's in college I don't know that's
that's cool so what I would do oh [ __ ]
another thanks reinforcement over here
there's gonna be not to defend new TNA
clan r6s my game is still updating ten
minutes left
can't wait but of the stream thanks Mike
might have read that green arrow says
when she Bluffs in terms of the flash
main thing oh okay cool thank you what
something Nathaniel boville I think
that's how you say him sweet so hit the
hostage that did my job as mute but now
I gotta hide from Bray 'then Macaulay I
think it's been out look at this okay
look how dirty this is what is this is
my little hiding spot usually gonna come
in here so now it not even lying can see
me okay I I probably would have a
greater appreciation if I really
understood but but like lion if he's
scans I can move around all I want in
this circle and he's not gotcha he'll be
all like fall security and [ __ ]
I see but outside of that I'm gonna go
so Steve Bailey see check
apparently there is an ash elite
Nathaniel that is free however you would
have had to have played a match
beforehand however it's also apparently
broken right now for some people so just
be mindful
not while your team is not doing so hot
stay here come on vigil right here see
they don't know I'm here because all
your other teammates know no [ __ ]
cargo dad he wasn't he oh you walked
into his line that's welcome to I think
it's a good thing no no spray-and-pray
you know yeah I mean but it's bad one
yeah that happens but you know he didn't
mean it
no unfortunately yeah alright we're
going to we're going oh we want yeah oh
no okay it looks like you're too much
suffering what do you wanna do and it's
up to you what do you want to do one
more alright we'll do one more there's
two Ashley's games yeah so one new one
and then one that you should have caught
as a make good from Ubisoft but
apparently some of those are having
issues but you V Soph knows they've
already said that so just be aware that
that's happening also if you're having
that weird thing where you're knocking
your for free outbreak packs
you know reload your game pretty much
this is a part of my personal account
hey I am infinity I'm only after I reset
my everything I'm like rank 22 so not
gold or silver
we're not playing ranked [ __ ] killers
says he was told the zombies was really
bad I think it's what do you to what you
would accept par for the course and I
think if you like you know plenty member
will succeed you ready and you know
playing the operators there's 10 of them
you get to experience them in a
different way I guess you know in a more
like cooperative way yeah and there are
definitely people that enjoy playing
that way so what do you do can you
change your gun can't you change your
gun if you don't like your gun I mean I
like it better than the other thing okay
that's better
so the Damascus steel skin is not
showing up dr. illinois' 26 I think is
what it is well outbreak stay on rainbow
six or rainbow after the 27 days and the
game reminds me of left 4 dead as of
right now all we know is that it's gonna
last for 27 days eight
hours and 34 more minutes I got to move
us out of the way so I got extra credits
I could okay I can get some outbreak
packs while we're here so I'll do an
outbreak tackle it's down there in the
bottom right no word as to if it'll be
extended or anything after that oh well
that's not Elena in a pack get a couple
of them probably expenses at some point
but transaction failed in my offline now
did I get kicked I don't know what is
going on it's like now let me do a few
things new TNA clan our success aroma
succeed Rowley sorry to ask well what
are your names
hold on let me get the pit back that's
Mike I'm Erica I have to restart or
something
Jared this Aaron is this game fun or
born online right now I think my renoun
just disappeared
I think that um it's fun if you like
competitive shooters or if you want to
try that like PvE co-op experience
that's available now so that could be up
your alley but you know it's up to you
if there we go this game is fun or not I
mean Mike enjoys it a bit and quite a
bit I haven't played too much I enjoy
watching them it's good going says they
are having server problems that's
possible is day one of a new kind of
patch and operation time Mira
first time it hasn't been balanced with
new people new characters they're both
attackers this time people I mean
different defenses are apparently the
server issues have been going on for a
little bit so we've been lucky I think
for the most part - that one game the
first game we had which was really we
were having a real tough time with our
opinion but everything else is good yeah
some people are saying that in chat here
you can't see it but I'll show it to you
there they're also struggling with -
problem people did some people did
that's also what our story says but yeah
if you're suffering from that and not
getting the Asha lead skin the one that
if you had played a match prior to the
sixth which is today then just hold hold
on tight because Ubisoft knows roopinder
body saying a nice cheeky tactic is you
can bait attackers in hostage by hiding
behind the hostage after the line scan
some people are saying oh no it's a nerf
I think someone asked sorry if I missed
your name but they're like is do you
feel lion is Opie
[Music]
what I wouldn't say Oh b-but you got
mean like yeah I think maybe I know the
I know the Lord doesn't support vigil
being invisible but I think it any more
than one counter for something that
powerful and right now it meets the only
legit counter hmm mine mechanic one of
the old maps that's back is yacht as
green area I'd mentioned so what do you
think about starting the round with that
as they like move out it could be useful
I guess have you trying to get over if
you're trying to see if you don't scan
them and you don't know what rumors they
have you want to see if calves or Ella's
wandering around that it can be helpful
Oh talk about some look at the draw
there Mike while you waltz across a
little spot to look up his bad aim and
they're just shredding thanks Joe
appreciate that comment beaks are
casting
thanks for the view he's also in the
wrong stream because oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god I can't move yeah I
see em except heat in here you say
that's it that's fine
what the fog don't know that was bad
shooting on my part and that's it
someone killing please give us a name
yeah I just went that was my fault
completely
I don't know if it's out for console
yeah a lot of people are saying they
were having problems with that so hard
to say Joe a multiplayer seems fine I
mean like it might be a little bit worse
today because it's the first day and it
sounds like they're having some server
issues but I think for the other like
for most of the other times my XY played
it's been fine other than our internet
being kind of messed up yeah savage
shots did you get a free port yeah but
it wasn't even just the games it was
like getting into you play it was tough
and then it wasn't our internet cuz I I
did I was in sorry yeah I was in you
play but I couldn't get into a game yeah
yeah I'm guessing that's just overload
from all the stuff happening today but
stabbed shots did you get your free four
packs no we didn't but as mentioned if
you're not getting the packs close your
game to reopen you should get the packs
if you still don't then not sure what to
tell you there other than Ubisoft knows
about that as an issue I guess that was
their way to fix it
hopefully I'll get my on my sign back on
my desk or something
do you know if yacht is back and ranked
I don't know okay
I'm assuming if it's in casual I don't
think they put any one and not the other
but I could be wrong about that a good
question because that is apparently it's
out on console but those servers are
stuck in snow partly they use not in
casual I'd much rather have yacht than
Bartley you though DJ bad says out for
God stop that Xbox updates ten gigs cool
yeah I'm not sure if yacht is unranked
or not so unfortunately I can tell you
sorry
Oh 45 someone spawned peeking I always
not screw up this time and have terrible
aim so they're right here okay left
already
kai love it
there are two Asha lead scans just so
you know I'm some
nice glass with the kill I'm not gonna
even try that window anymore [ __ ] that
broken something [ __ ] someone's right
there nice this glass is killin people
I'm trying to let my play this round out
then all asking these questions
so either diffuser I could go try to
plant I guess Joshua I know we did play
outbreak ready you can scrub back
through the DVR like 20 20 or so minutes
ago
30
what's up page doom sir he's still there
where oh he's on the stairs okay sweet
watch this you lyin her finger you can
use her power lighters what's on the
same yeah I know there's no point got
him once didn't kill him who God he's
right about me got a plan
sounds like it's behind you
over here yes he's close
he was chillin yeah if I should have
planned it earlier I thought they
planted nope no I should have planted
earlier than that all G Oh what's up
Sean Regan yeah there's a fail camera
and that's right as I don't know glasses
face and YouTube saying bugs are that no
pack no skin and no base ops I'm walking
apparently there's a ball cam by the
window
Pamela's long left on the top wait for
updates
like hey please kill me
well my disruptor [ __ ] them up I'm just
saved one of these from when Lyons about
what's up rise kid 96 how you doing
what's the the bait plant might have
worked there and I was close I mean I
should've just planted Eric he's right
oh [ __ ] oh hello finca goddamn boy
you're so dead right
are you dead yeah at least you got one
though yeah they all came in up top
looks like good luck for the team three
before bed
miles Peters as mentioned the packs are
one of the bugs if you have that try
exiting out and coming back if not it's
a probably something they will fix and
you'll get them don't worry they know
about it no I don't know the answer to
that question about your 5-hour energy
drink problem rise good sorry I reckon
people he's going in and mailing the
crap out of them murk okay all right
that was fun not the way we would I
suggest PC plastics just because it's a
game about like precise aiming yeah I
mean it's fine on ps4 for sure but I
definitely recommend PC so thanks Mike
day to back-to-backs
Thank You Sherman Randall I haven't
decided
but Pete had thrown out maybe
Scribblenauts as a thing oh yeah I was
uh maybe entertaining the pub G Xbox one
update because I know that's a thing I
don't know yet haven't decided Thursday
I know that the or talented women here
in the office are gonna do a stream for
International Women's Day and then
Friday we're gonna have Monster Hunter
Fridays as usual so any last thoughts on
outbreak new operators operation
Camarillo a lot of it okay this is game
I'm playing mostly yeah so if it's if
you have your three pasts you have the
OP the operators today right line and
finca if not you'll get you'll get the
chance to possibly buy them with
renowned if you want to for I think it's
like twenty five thousand right now and
is what they said earlier next week 13th
but outbreak is also available so if you
want to try that out there's 27 days 18
hours and 19 minutes left so check out
that limited time event co-op PvE
experience but until next time thanks
everyone
sound good Tuesday or today's Wednesday
isn't it today's Tuesday
all right have a good Tuesday later I
don't know every day anything
everything's all the same